we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
voicemail that came in yesterday hey
David
just to comment about that you were
talking about the dog whistles Trump
uses in terms of like make you know
America first saw that was another one I
spread on Twitter someone was saying
that apparently the term sleepy eyes
communities called Chuck Todd sleepy
eyes Todd apparently that's also
historically anti-semitic a dog whistle
as well but it's pretty commonly used on
Stormfront to describe Jewish people
yeah well that was interesting
is they're interested up there actually
is I mean again we don't know whether
Trump is knowingly using these as dog
whistles because he knows the background
down at whether it's talking about brown
immigrant reproduction as breeding or
whether it's referring to America first
or in this case referring to Chuck Todd
is sleepy eyes but there is a bunch of
old sort of I mean I think Nazi
literature is really the only way to say
it which talked about ways to identify
Jews and sleepy eyes was part of that so
again it is a reference to an
anti-semitic phrase but does Trump know
that I couldn't tell you you know Ben
Carson who was a very lethargic guy I
think he was only referred to as sleepy
ben Carson not sleepy eyes ben Carson
that's true it's a little bit suspicious
I think very very suspicious yeah but
more than likely Trump does not actually
know that these are dog whistles but
someone does who's feeding them to Trump
and who knows by the way at this point
who's helping Trump can [ __ ] those
tweets right we don't know the he hires
someone to come up with the moniker is
like someone had to develop lying Ted or
crooked Hillary if they have a whole
room of people coming up with these and
he just picks the best one it's sort of
hard to believe Trump's exclusively
coming up with them on his own but I
know that he does seem to have a
penchant for insulting people so it
actually might be something is good at
low energy jeb lyin Ted crazy Bernie
cycling thumb he they're like little bob
Corker who ever came out what that needs
to be fired
Lidl ' yeah we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about night
owls having a ten percent higher
mortality risk and this relates to a lot
of Homo sapiens related studies about
being up all night being bad for your
health will talk about Starbucks closing
all company owned stores on May 29th for
racial bias education day and we will
also talk about a former President
George HW Bush being hospitalized just
days after the passing of Barbara Bush
his wife of 73 years all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
two ways to access the bonus show become
a member at david pakman.com slash
membership become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
will speak to you then